another massacre
uvalde texas
in elementary school
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders tragedy hits
texas
at least 18 students and three adults
were killed in a mass shooting at robb
elementary school
to lose a child
it's like having a piece of your soul
ripped away
so tonight
i ask the nation to pray for them
give the parents and siblings the
strength
and the darkness they feel right now
senator chris murphy immediately took to
the congressional floor with a
passionate plea for gun control reform
why are we here
if not to try to make sure that fewer
schools and fewer communities go
through what sandy hook has gone through
what yuvaldi is going through
celebrities are now taking to social
media to express their feelings uzzo
aduba shares this series of broken heart
emojis many stars also speak out for gun
control reform in their messages mandy
moore writes quote there are no words we
must take action khloe kardashian says
quote what good is protecting our
freedoms when there is no protection of
our lives
the tragedy has also affected the season
4 finale of cbs's fbi
fbi
the network has pulled the episode as it
revolves around stolen automatic weapons
and the danger of those guns ending up
in the hands of a school student
appearing eerily similar to the texas
shooting the tragedy hits close to home
for an a-list celeb as well matthew
mcconaughey was born in uvalde texas the
site of the mass shooting speaking with
et in 1996 the actor shares his love for
the people in his native state
this is home for me there's a it's a
very close extension of
the family and a very good sense of
community around here and i like the
the the innocence and the honesty
very good good people et has reached out
to mcconaughey's reps for comment
you